[Music]
so this is kind of funny I was recently
thinking about showers
I looked it up how long showers have
actually been in our culture and in
society you with these people oh my god
ladies and gentlemen this is a real and
rare joy one of my good friends of
comedy he likes to drop by the show
sometimes to try out some of his new
jokes this is a thrill would you help me
in welcoming new material Seinfeld
everybody material new material good to
see you it's been too long look good oh
thanks you two you two you were you
working on some new stuff yeah can I run
a few new by you yeah I mean yes
sure I got this new bit about apples
okay apples eat have you ever noticed
that apples are the only fruit that
comes in multiple colors green yellow
red yeah okay am I in the produce
section or at a stoplight I mean I feel
sorry for the orange that's the only
color it's allowed to be orange haven't
seen a green orange you think it's an
apple this green apple tastes like an
orange stop somebody
[Laughter]
[Applause]
red apple stop this stop like the
stoplight readout yeah stop sign perhaps
that's red too
I think you should try it I mean then
God allow Thank You Pete my dog got
fixed why do they call it fixed when he
can't make puppies anymore but I can't
get my wife pregnant
they say there's something wrong with me
dog can't do that all of a sudden he's
fixed then I teach him not to pee in the
house
they say he's housebroken but he's drunk
and he's fixed when he's fixed he's
broken I don't get it I must be fixed I
mean I I think that's funny right
I mean you mature he'll no kidding
that is ready to go that is so close to
real I love it that's good I got a gig
with Romano this weekend I'll try it out
one more Pete yeah I mean we will do the
show but let's we have time over one
more let's see one more
well thank you
why is a pancake called a pancake but a
cake is just called a cake you make a
cake in a pan - that's right you got a
cake pan then you make a grilled cheese
in a pan get out rolling it should be
called a pan cheese cheese
[Music]
[Laughter]
just I mean flawless victory that is so
good maybe maybe you could do something
about other cakes cupcakes pancakes
maybe you could mind your own business
I'm trying to do a Seinfeld joke not a
paint Holmes routine if this was a
Holmes bid I'd be up there square and
then smiling like a jackass the material
side bout everybody
[Applause]
[Music]